Mike Florio co-host of pro football talk
live pro football talk comm kind enough
to join us Mike
according to your report Gronk according
to a source of 40% chance that he'd be
coming back to play with the Patriots
I'm curious if that's if that's up from
like 30% or is that down from 50% or
down from a hundred percent yeah I think
if anything the trend is to horde wrong
being inclined once the game start then
once he sees the train roll on without
him getting that itch the question is
will he scratch it and I think the most
significant thing I was told yesterday
about wrong the idea that his tall Brady
at some point picks up the phone
and makes a direct appeal to bran to
come back but that could be the thing
that pushes it over the top and we know
how the Patriots tend to struggle early
in the season wishing them swamp
relative to their usual standards
through September from time to time
you've got a lot of transition in the
receiving corps and maybe Tom Brady gets
sufficiently exasperated after three or
four weeks that he does make that phone
call to draw what will Ron say if it
happens and I think it's all to be
determined because we don't know how
Broncs going to feel when the regular
season starts and most importantly he
doesn't know how he's going to feel
until the regular season starts running
backs salaries is always an issue you
know in and we're trying to figure out
their value and how do you pay them
commensurate to what they do for a team
or what they mean to a team and I don't
know if there is an answer to that but
you were talking about Zeke Elliott you
know might be holding out Melvin Gordon
might be holding out Le'Veon Bell I
don't know if he's the anomaly or he's
the trend here where are we going with
running backs salaries well here's the
problem with running backs especially
guys who are taken in the first round
because you've got that fifth year
option which delays their opportunity to
get to the open market for the most part
the team gets the maximum performance
that anyone is ever going to get out of
that running back in those first several
years of his rookie contract so then
when the time comes to paying the
question is is he going to keep playing
like he has are we paying him big money
for the downward slide of his career
either because of one specific injury
just the accumulation of wear and tear
the guy goes through when you touch the
ball 20 to 25 per game so a per game
over the course of the 16-game season
and and it's hard to find that sweet
spot and I think that's why it's smart
the dizzy to Elliott is taking his stand
now because if he waits another year or
two two more years his rookie contract
expires and nothing keeps the Cowboys
from doing to him what they did to
DeMarco burn DeMarco Murray finished his
rookie contract with a franchise record
in single-season rushing yards he led
the NFL in rushing the cowboy said see
you later and he went inside with the
Philadelphia Eagles so I think that the
key is while you are still at your
maximum level of output find that moment
where you say I want my money give me my
money Chris Johnson did that with the
Titans in 2011 I think Melvin Gordon's
over playing his hand he's not a truly
special running fact there's a small
handful at any given time a truly
special running back Elliott is still
that he needs to get paid while he still
falls into that category because whether
it's one year two years three years
Miller talked early a year ago he was
one of the special backs now he's not
because of that eight problem it can
happen quickly so you need to take a
stand get paid while you can we'll dak
Prescott G Kelly and Amari Cooper all
get paid in Dallas this year I think
it's got to be difficult to pay all
through it they're going to have to
really do some creative things under the
salary cap and I think chains have more
freedom than they would admit under the
salary cap to make things work sometimes
they just don't feel like making it work
they don't feel like finding a way to
spend the money they don't feel like
going to ten different veterans and
trying to create tab space that way if
you really want to do it they can I mean
the problem is Cooper and Prescott of
the two who are due to be free agents
next year Elliott got two years left in
the callable we could kind of hope to
finesse this where they could wait on
Elliott if Ally it pushes this thing to
a head
they're going to have to let either
Cooper or Prescott play out that rookie
contract and if they let both play out
the rookie contract Dan you can only use
a franchise tag on one of the next year
the other one's going to get market
value somewhere the NFL floated the idea
of 18 games schedule I've heard 17 games
might be a better option maybe there's
added playoff
spots here but you know when there's
money big money at stake here then I
throw logic out the window so well where
do you think things are going to stand
when this season starts with the
possibility of an 18-game schedule in
the near future
well I shot that there's a new
collective bargaining agreement in place
before the start of the season I just
don't think it's practical
now the players have some leverage as it
relates to getting the thing done by the
start of the regular season at least
have an agreement at principle and and
they'd be wise to find a way to use it
but they really have leverage on the
NFL's obsession with expanding the
regular seed and whether it's 18 right
away whether it's 17 for a while and
then 18 I think the NFL is determined to
do it the one thing the NFLPA has done
incredibly well dan they have created
the impression that they're just not
interested you're talking about poker
faces the a has the ultimate poker face
on expanding the regular-season because
they will love it no we don't want it we
don't want it we don't want it and I
think at some point what the NFL is
going to do is make the NFLPA and offer
they can't refuse and I thought people
say well the NFLPA should ask for this
no that's for anything we don't want it
and you change our mind and if you
eventually put something on the table
that changes our mind so be it but we
don't want it and and that gives them a
hell of a lot of power and we'll see if
the NFL ever makes them an offer that
they truly can't refuse but I think
that's the way they need to play it
that's the way they've been playing it
and they're putting themselves in
position to really get a significant
amount of money to agree to expanding
the regular-season I just think it's a
matter of time until the NFL makes that
type of an offer but when you're saying
you know the answer is no and that's
what I was told that it's absolutely
know that there's no way that the
players union is going to take an 18
game regular season schedule but I is it
just money is that the one thing that
you can give to these players then could
you could you say we want contracts
guaranteed well here's the thing about
guaranteed contracts keep this in mind
if you guaranteed all contracts there
would be no NFL contract longer than
three years and most of them would be
one year or two years you're not going
to sign a quarterback to a six year
fully guaranteed contract because what
if come here for he's no good you're
stuck with him so they look at the
Vikings they get a three-year fully
guaranteed
tract with dozens that they may really
want to tear up after this season but
they're not going to be able to do it so
shorter contracts will will be what
happens and maybe not food for the
players maybe shorter contracts are
better to get back to free agency sooner
instead of being caught on the back end
of a non guaranteed deal that gives a
team all the power but then I think
terms like a shorter path to free agency
right out of the gates three years
instead of four years you know those are
the kind of terms unrelated the money
there's a split of the money between
ownership and the players that could get
the attention of the NFLPA
expanded rosters would be a necessity if
you're going to play 18 games how many
roster spots are there going to be
and again I would negotiate if I was the
players I would say sold everyone on the
idea that they don't want 18 games so we
don't we absolutely positively don't
want 18 games until the moment we decide
we'll take 18 games because you've made
us an offer between money and roster
spots and pathway to free agency and
whatever else the NFL feels compelled to
throw on the pile to get this 18-game
schedule that they so clearly want one
more item let me circle back to Ezekiel
Elliott because you know I I know Jerry
Jones is just desperate for that one
more Super Bowl and he's going to take
you know do whatever he can to get this
done I'm just surprised that Zeke what
kind of leverage does he have two years
out to say that he wants a new deal as
opposed to and given what's happened in
the offseason and troubles that he's had
like why am i acquiesce 'king to him two
years out because Jerry Jones
desperately wants to win another Super
Bowl because Jerry Jones lives through
the Emmitt Smith situation in 1993 when
he held out into the regular season the
Cowboys lost the first three games Jerry
Jones caved and then the Cowboys became
the first team that NFL history to start
over to and with the Super Bowl so the
blueprints there and Elliott and Steven
Jones was on PFC live with me right
after the draft and we talked about the
timetable for Elliott Steele and he said
Ezekiel Elliott is the straw that stirs
our drink okay well then you got a pan
you got to pay him before these other
guys in and that's the other reason why
LA should take a stand out there pay
attention to what's going on with the
offensive Dallas there Kellogg or is the
court
they're going to make the offense much
more dynamic and creative than it ever
has been maybe a year from now it's more
about that Prescott Amari Cooper and it
is about Ezekiel Elliott this year
though is still about Elliott and now
going into this year
Elliott I think it's the perfect time
for him to take a stand because Jerry
Jones is desperate to win because the
offense still goes through him he's
still the straw that stirs the drink
they may have a different straw next
year so now's the time to get that straw
pay because again look I'll go back to
talk early if the Rams would never give
talk Gurley now the deal they gave up a
year ago they were early and his people
were smart to get the deal that they got
when they did because one year can
change everything for a running back and
that's why Elliott needs to take that
stand thank you Mike as always we
appreciate your time all right it's a
Mike Florio co-host of pro football talk
live pro football talk.com for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]